yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Marshall 91 oh it's got a really
high rating
okay the bullet rating is 1900 yeah and
this blitz rating is two thousand five
hundred ninety yeah okay it sounds a
little bit odd let's see what we get
I'm gonna this line yeah yeah this is
supposed to be a little bit better for
white this variation but it's not like
terrible for black let's see what is
going to continue with ya here you
usually capture and I should try to get
okay this is now getting entirely
different entirely different direction
after he went c5
and 97 looks kind of normal now it's a
little bit odd what black did here
giving me this opportunity I mean it's
not like I'm winning or anything but
it's a little bit odd that that he
allowed us yeah I mean you have to cover
c6 somehow I guess so night e7 looks
very normal okay new I guess taking is
fine and tell me black it's not a
terrible shape here let's see about it
yeah I wonder this light should go to d3
that would be a really nice square but
it's not easy to get down the thing that
I'm wondering about is if black will
play it d3 at any any moment
hmm I don't know it's tough to say I
have this move is really helpful or not
there's no really easy way to get the
night to get the night to d3c five would
be a good way but you will play queen
before here fairly certain and I should
probably call b3
hmm okay yeah I think I'm let me let me
block this for the time being I really
don't know what you make of possible ad
3
yeah I don't really see how I can get
the night to d3 maybe some pawn to b4
195
I have a before mistake it would be a
today 5 maybe it's still a good idea
only three the night is so nice because
it does everything and like it covers b2
covers before covers all kinds of good
squares a useful squares and yeah I
could have gone b3 okay now he goes c5
that's interesting okay the night might
come to c6 so I should probably route
this so I'll move it back just to be
able to take on c6 if if I need to go
here
ninety-two the 93r so one day I won't go
there maybe I'm too much focused on that
on that idea yeah but I got there got
there at the end
No
just prevented Quincy for okay
not sure about this and I think it's
it's kind of useful to play
okay so if I take the screen h1 now
hmm okay
mm I don't know if that is really
helping putting the knife down h5 is
hanging you but this this Queen d2 and
d3 I mean okay I mean I really miss is
just playing against an engine it's very
obvious but you still have to make make
moves and you cannot just resign I
reported me will get banned we know the
deal but it's so kind of always a real
waste of time
otherwise it's extremely point let's see
how this game as it was obvious that it
is a cheetah from from from the very
beginning that count was just so
extremely fishy you don't have nineteen
hundred or something and in in bullet
and then rematch a screw you that would
be an immediate band just crazy this
idiot okay so where's the band let me do
that right away let's top 100 yeah
that's easy so where is that report
sheet catch checkmate in one move really
okay send please one linkage she did
came okay where was the link sorry that
you have to go all this but I don't want
to I don't want to forget about it you
know
and it can easily happen a you play game
of the game of the game and then you
forget to report this [ __ ] also I have
to solve it again
yeah let's block it the engine I mean
and now we can look at this game maybe
this was kind of maybe interesting I
don't know it's not really interesting
in some way sorry but let's have a look
then
yeah so we had this opening which is a
fairly fairly normal
this is also funny like yeah like he
spent like half a minute yeah maybe
getting is his his stuff fired up
because 97 is then it's what you play I
mean it's just what you play what what
else is there I would see 8 or 27 or
whatever so yeah so here you had it all
set up
and so I shouldn't take know if I've the
whole thing what I'm doing is not really
working to my advantage ok so but like I
would still like to be interested in
we're screwed it up so I mean I was ok
for a long time for sure so yeah I think
this stuff should be around equal his
bishop it's not really a great piece
yeah I'm kind of okay here yeah maybe
this was really not great yeah just you
three f3 I mean I was kind of you know
if you play against an engine you just
you try to keep it as simple as possible
this is why I went to prevent you for a
queen II form but maybe it's not it's
not it's not best and here I'm getting
into huge trouble
what is his stats 0 13 edits 1
inaccuracy probably in the opening or
when when he was totally winning already
like him and this is probably debatable
that it's really inaccurate no it's it's
actually the best move after a little
bit more time this automatic it's
automatically you know this thing and if
you take him on the chrimbus it is
actually not in accuracy so probably he
was closer to the engine then this
automatic automatic function here
provides yeah then you have the or
cheetah on every platform so this is one
of those games
I'll get the points back I guess it
takes it takes a moment but I'll get it
back ok I hope that was still of some
interest to you thanks for watching